hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
prolonged isolation amid the coronavirus
pandemic
taking a toll on many americans and it's
proving to have a devastating effect
on young people's mental health
superintendent of nevada's clark county
school district
dr jesus jarrah opens up about the
county's push
to partially reopen schools in response
to a rise in students
taking their own lives the biden
administration working to buy 200
million more covet 19 vaccine doses
but public health experts still
anticipate a tough road ahead
dr marty mccary a professor of surgery
and health policy at johns hopkins
university
and a fox news medical contributor
breaks down concerns over the vaccine
roll out
different strains of the virus and the
effectiveness of restrictions
being enforced across the country plus
commentary from fox news legal analyst
greg
jarrett the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
lee companio i'm guy benson i'm shannon
breme and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
wednesday january 27 2021
i'm lisa brady there's a national debate
about
fully reopening schools in a pandemic
but one nevada district
is on a mission concerned it's costing
lives to keep them closed
these are children who are struggling
and we have to
continue to find ways to help them
i'm dave anthony the push to pick up the
pace of covet vaccinations
comes amid worry about virus variants
given the rate of new mutations and
these new strains that are emerging are
we going to be able to keep up
at some point is it going to mutate
around the vaccine
and that's a very real and serious
question and the answer is
maybe at some point and i'm greg jarrett
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
one of the biggest challenges on the way
out of the pandemic
is when and how to get kids back in
school
across the country there's a patchwork
of in-person or remote learning and in
many areas
still a hybrid of the two i think that
president biden's goal
is really important the president wants
a majority of k-8 schools reopen in his
first 100 days
and randy weingarten president of the
american federation of teachers
says that can be a real goal unless new
strains of covet interfere
but it's also not clear when more
federal funding might arrive to help
with expanded safety measures like
testing and ventilation systems
and some teachers aren't satisfied with
existing safety plans
if you're trying to force us back into
the building
give us a real plan a schedule
a link to get tested linda perales
teaches in chicago
where the union wants all teachers
vaccinated before
in-person learning resumes but the
nation's third largest district has
argued that some
families can't wait any longer while the
risk of covet transmission
in school is considered low there's been
growing concern about the risk of
other problems for kids who aren't
learning in person
from falling grades and social
interaction setbacks
to mental health issues even suicide in
the nation's
fifth largest school district which
includes las vegas
18 students took their own lives between
last march and december
the youngest just nine years old that
was double the number from the previous
year
though there's no proven link to school
closures
they have been troubling as a school
system and as a community
dr jesus jarrah is the clark county
superintendent
it's something that i am extremely
concerned
when our kids you know are struggling
emotionally
i say this quite often
it's hard for adults to deal with the
global pandemic
that we've never dealt with and and
that's when i started thinking about
the challenge that teenagers and
children
are probably facing as the economy
shutting down everything
that we've known and that's part of
where
we started trying to find ways to bring
solutions and support
our kids who are struggling but yeah
you're right i can't conclusively link
it
but i have a strong feeling that the
isolation
that's happening in our for our kids for
our children
um has a lot to do with our mental
health
well-being well and when you have
um the number of suicides doubling over
over nine months compared to the year
before you know
what's different about that nine months
well
the pandemic correct the pandemic which
that's exactly the biggest concern on
the
that we have and no explanation
which has caused the economic crisis you
know when you see your parents
struggling
when your number one industry in las
vegas
and clark county is hotel link casinos
that's one of the things that you see
the
really the challenges that my families
are facing at home
and how did how do we deal with that in
children having to grow up quickly
uh but not having an outlet
to be able to come to school to find
normalcy in their life
play athletics the band the choir some
of the
the what my kids were facing were using
as a
as a tool to escape it's all gone i know
before the pandemic
youth suicide rates in the country had
been on the rise for a decade
um what are some of the things that your
district has been doing
to try to address that issue yeah you
know
that's a great question one of the
things that we started you know
obviously increasing the
um support from the state grants on
mental health
bringing social workers you know even
though we don't have enough right i mean
public education there's there's a lot
of resources that are lacking but the
state had made an investment
um on mental health support for kids uh
for schools
when we started this pandemic when we
started you know
with the closure and then not connecting
to our kids not finding
them um we retooled our our staffing
you know we removed our truancy officers
from truancy officers checking on kids
uh for truancy was more checking on kids
for wellness
uh checking on that they were home that
they were connecting with our
with our schools so we've made some
drastic investments
up in the last seven seven to eight
months
and i know teachers were trained as well
to start
being able to spot the cues of trauma on
screen
as opposed to in person but then by the
summer time
there had been so many suicides that
a new program was launched right the i
think it's called the go
guardian beacon alert system which sends
kind of alerts
uh sends out alerts when it's thought
that
there's a suicide risk yeah let me tell
you a little bit about that works i mean
that was added to our chromebooks that
we that we
that we purchased um and it was really
through artificial intelligence where
kids are googling or surfing
you know how to harm themselves it sends
us
it sends my executive team and our
police department and alert
and then it alerts you know whether it's
my you know
we have our own police department our
police department or municipalities are
alerted
and then they go home and do a wellness
check um
you know we have been able to get at
least to one or two a couple
where you know obviously where they were
in the middle of the act and i think
that's been
um you know where you find that some of
the things that we are putting in place
um to provide that support for our kids
who
who are struggling to to be able to help
the families
wow i mean a child may not always
spell it out that they're about to
attempt something but through that
system
i'm sure there are certain words that
are red flags or phrases
and then the alert goes out were you
surprised by how many
alerts started coming in from that
computerized system
it's shocking um i get um i i get maybe
about five
six a day on average um
and in the middle of the night where you
know as as i continue
um i've kind of had to put my phone
aside really
um because they come in nightly and and
it is shocking it is surprising that
um but we're not going to stop we're
we're going to continue
to do what we can um you know our social
workers our
our psychologists our counselors are
doing everything they can
these are these are children who are
struggling and we have to
continue to find ways to help them
what else do you think could help
identify students who may be at risk and
are there ways that
the state or federal governments can do
more to help with that
you know right now it's it's we need to
talk about it i mean one of the parents
that that i spoke to
um it's something that's a taboo it's
not discuss
and i think awareness is one because you
don't know i mean one of the parents
didn't know
uh honor student and i think this is
gonna be we don't know the effects of
all of this
um academically we we know we're we're
falling behind with the world pandemic
that we're dealing with
uh now it's emotional we don't know what
the future
um impact um so the the federal
government
has to really invest in mental health
and
and i've had that conversations with our
congressional leaders
um because these are going to have
long-term effects on our families
on our kids and our employees there's
days that i struggle
yeah there's uh
there's a lot of struggle to go around
right um
and it's kind it's definitely
complicated especially where
the kids are concerned um i have two
so thinking about my own kids a middle
schooler and a high schooler
i get emotional because it's it really
is difficult on so many levels
but when it comes to reopening schools i
mean the president
has certainly proposed more money to
help with that but
but how do you do it like what needs to
actually
change to get people feeling safe going
into schools i'm sure your district
you know in many districts with hybrid
models in place have already had safety
measures
to have students there and have staff
there on a limited basis
so what is it that needs to be done to
actually get
you know everyone back in the building
safely
i think right now um you're right i
think the
the hybrid model that we're looking at
for pre-k 3 is going to help is going to
see where you start seeing the light at
the end of the tunnel
i think the vaccine is going to be
critical
um to be able to vaccinate where there's
that level of
safety and assurance as an adult that
there's a mitigating effort for me to be
vaccinated to have that
immunity right we're also you know part
of our opening plan has um
testing for covert testing for our
employees
where there's that level of assurance as
well
what about families who may not want
their kids back in school if they're
someone who's high risk at home for
instance high risk for for covid
um complications um but then worries
that their child might be punished
if they don't go back to school when
everybody goes back what what can be
done for those families
there's going to be those families
there's going to be those educators so
we need to find a way to offer that
choice and that option for families
and we have a plan to do that um that's
part of where
my my opening for pre-k 3 is for those
who want to come
so if you as a as a as a kid because
your family says no
then we're going to continue with
distance education for you
but that's going to be an option i've
been when we're moving into
having that opportunity for all my
all the kids that want to stay home for
whatever reason and offering that choice
but your thrust right now the big
picture for you is
an urgent desire if you will
an urgent plan to get as many kids back
in schools
as quickly as possible is is that right
yeah
my urge is my i have a sense of urgency
to start
moving into face-to-face instruction for
pre-k 3
as soon as we can what about the
the later elementary grades the middle
schoolers the high schoolers
is that is that a fall situation or
could it be before the end of this
school year i'm hoping that you know
obviously i'm going slow
right i'd rather go slow and move move
forward
up and then start moving into um as soon
as i can then go back to the
you know we're going to try it out with
a small group and then we're going to
then continue and start seeing where
there's
everybody sees that there's that is that
is safe
we can then start um opening up some you
know
our fourth and fifth and our middle
schools and hopefully get to our high
schools by the end of the year if i can
get there
when we finally do turn a corner in this
pandemic
are you hopeful that more attention
will still be paid to the issue of
mental health and
making sure kids who need it get help
absolutely
i hope that this conversation is not
just now
this is a conversation that we need to
have in the near future
and it's a long conversation we need to
invest our kids
and i'll tell you our adults i mean i'm
not going to say that our teachers
um need support as well all our
educators we all do and i think that's
the piece that's the investment that
we need to make in this country the
mental health
of our children is is top priority if
you don't feel that
you're safe to learn then how could we
expect you to learn how to do
how to read and do math and arithmetic
well thanks for all you do for the kids
the clark county superintendent
dr jesus jarrah thank you very much for
your time we appreciate it
thank you so much the national suicide
prevention lifeline is available
24 hours a day that number is
1-800-273-8255
[Music]
this is greg jarrett with your fox news
commentary coming up
we could never have imagined this one
year ago the coronavirus pandemic has
now topped
a hundred million cases around the world
and that's just the number of people
confirmed to have had it
total infections maybe a lot higher of
course now we have vaccines
and president biden is upping the ante
on his pledge for a hundred million
shots in his first hundred days
i think we may be able to get that to
150
1.5 million a day rather than one
million a day
though there have been issues with that
the director of the cdc said the other
day she's not sure
how much supply there is and
distribution's been uneven better in
some places than others
white house press secretary jen sachi
says a priority
is ensuring that states have the number
of vaccinators they need so that means
people who are literally taking the
shots and qualified to put them in the
arms of americans
and some states and some communities
don't have people who
are able to do that and vaccine centers
and places where people can go
and when those issues are worked out
biden advisor dr anthony fauci tells fox
by the time you get to april you will
have gotten to the point
where when i would i refer to it for
simplicity
as open season when we all might be able
to get on that list to get a dose
back now to the president's goal we
actually hit
a one and a half million vaccines per
day last
friday dr marty mccary is professor of
surgery and health policy at johns
hopkins
and a fox news contributor weekends tend
to be lower so if you take a seven day
moving average we're not quite at that
rate
yet but two days into biden's presidency
we hit a million
vaccinations per day now look it should
be higher
we're about three weeks behind schedule
from the original stated goal of getting
20 million
people vaccinated by the end of last
calendar year
that's you know a tragedy but we're
actually humming right now and i think
what
the folks in the bible administration
are learning is that once the railroad
tracks are laid
this train can speed along pretty
quickly and that's where we
are right now but there have been
discrepancies state by state
some places it's hard to find vaccine
other places there's a ton of supply and
people are getting it real fast so what
do we do about that
yeah this was a real disappointment dave
so the cdc
came out with their guidance so late you
know they had nine months to work on it
and they came out with their guidance
two weeks after the vaccine was
authorized and distributed
so states were in this decision
paralysis hospitals were sitting around
everyone was telling me oh we're just
waiting for the guidance we
you know need to wait and see what we're
supposed to do it was so complicated the
tiering structure was so
convoluted we should just be going by
age that is the simple strategy that
allows us to
vaccinate the most amount of people in a
streamlined fashion that people can
understand which is important when it
comes to implementation
so we need to go down the age ladder and
hit the 40 to 50 million americans who
are willing to take the vaccine who are
between
who are over age 65 that's where 80
percent of the deaths are in people over
65
that's who we really gotta hit right now
with the vaccine
very doable the next 40 million doses
should go to them if they haven't gotten
it already
heck israel has already vaccinated 44
percent of their
entire population so we should be using
the age-based system
now my father-in-law is in new hampshire
he's on the list for next week he's
going to get his first dose of vaccine
a question is how long before immunity
starts to kick in for someone and then
after that
will they still need to wear masks does
my father-in-law to all these people
who've already gotten these coveted
vaccine doses do they need to keep
wearing masks
hold on to your mask it's very difficult
for any
public business or event to
have sort of two different policies and
so
for now given the low burden of masks if
we can keep wearing them for another two
or three months i think we're going to
be in such a good place
by april dave honestly we're going to be
in such a great place just look at the
rate of decline
of daily new cases it takes about 10 to
14 days for that immunity to start
kicking in
the immunity may be as good as 62
percent after
two weeks 80 to 90 percent after three
or four weeks before you even get the
second
dose and then the second dose will
augment it a little further
so i think we should be maximizing the
number of first doses out there before
we go to the second dose
but either way people should keep their
mask on until we get beyond this very
difficult next month
you know lately i've been hearing so
many more people talk about
double masks wearing two
and and then i've heard other people
talk about well the problem with masking
is not all masks are equal some people
have lousy masks some people have great
masks so should we
be wearing two well if you're really
concerned and you're high risk
i think it's a good idea if your mask is
a very low quality
cough cloth mask we know that the n95s
are over 90
effective the surgical masks what we
call
a level three surgical mask what i've
actually been wearing most of my life
those are actually about 50 to 60
percent effective and
they do a good job in the operating room
but some people are wearing very
cheap cloth masks that are very porous
and if you do
and you're really concerned a a second
mask
could be helpful you know fauchi said
this like last week and it created a big
stir
right it's kind of classic fouchy you
know he's about nine months late to the
party you know this is stuff we knew a
long time ago
but we weren't talking about double
masks last year too he wasn't even
talking about masks at all in march and
april the number of new coronavirus
cases
has declined recently
a day for almost two weeks in a row the
fewest covert patients in hospitals
since mid-december and a drop in deaths
some cities and states have eased or are
considering easing restrictions
in california governor gavin newsom has
lifted a stay home order
restaurants can open for outdoor dining
with modifications
nail hair salons can open with
modifications
certain use sports can resume for
competition
and there's no longer a nighttime curfew
so what does dr mccarry think we should
still consider restricting going forward
i think in areas where there are active
outbreaks
it is good to limit indoor
density and especially if the
ventilation's not good
then those limitations need to be even
higher
now look i'll go to public areas and
they'll have me sort of check out an
area like
you know i've worked with some sports
teams professional sports teams
and they have great ventilation they
have super high ceilings they have great
hepa filtration there you can allow
more people especially if they're
wearing masks
because it's almost like an outdoor
environment that's why bars have been
targeted is generally the ventilation is
not great it depends on the bar
you know we should probably also think
the same of churches they're not immune
from
these ventilation issues but i think
indoor gatherings it never made sense to
close beaches and never made sense to
close
parks we should we should have told
people to get outside when we told them
to stay at home
and just tell them to use the basic
precautions of distancing
we've had still for the last couple of
months
now moderna and pfizer only as the
vaccines approved
where are we in your view on johnson and
johnson
and astrazeneca which seem to be the
closest in the pipeline coming next
so johnson and johnson will likely get
their authorization in two weeks and
that's really good news because it's a
single dose does not require
a freezer chain and the supply
distribution
and it's badly needed and there's a
supply ready to go
so i think we're going to hear good news
about johnson and johnson you know any
hour now
dave they're going to be announcing the
results of their phase 3
trials and we're going to hear a number
like we did the 95
percent number with the other trials on
how effective it is
anything above 60 70 80 will be
well received so i think that's good the
other one the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine that is a
great american tragedy that has not been
authorized in the united states and not
even close
i mean april's the earliest and yet it
millions have been given out in europe
and europe and the uk have greenlighted
it
um and the the the tragedy is the fda
does not use rolling reviews they don't
look at data in real time
they're not using the data from the uk
they're insisting on another
entire trial to be completed and history
will look back and judge us as a country
because many americans have died because
of
the games that the fda played with that
oxford vaccine
it's the easiest to distribute we're
having all these problems with
distribution
that is the easiest to distribute
vaccine
ever made for coronavirus it's like the
flu shot
i mean simple refrigeration lasts at
least six months
no one has ever died from the vaccine
and the fda just needs to get their act
together
and do their patriotic duty and give
this a sound scientific review without
cutting any corners
and do it fast i mean this game about oh
we'd like to see another trial before we
authorize it well just look at the 10
million people in europe
that have taken it they're doing great
and that's our problem right now
at the fda there have been a lot of
people focusing on these new strains
from different places like the uk a
strain from south africa strain from
brazil
should we be worried about these and if
so what should we worry about
you know there was some a study that
came out of the uk that showed that the
variant they have
is not just more contagious it may
actually be 30 to 40 percent more lethal
more dangerous
and you know folks were sort of
dismissive of this idea that it could be
more
dangerous and said oh it's probably just
more contagious well guess what if it
binds more tightly to the h2 receptors
in your lung
if you have more viral load because it's
more sticky
then you're probably going to be sicker
and probably have a higher mortality and
so we're realizing that
now the uk strain at the current rate of
spread in the u.s could dominate by
march but i think we're going to see a
massive deceleration before then
and stem it off the brazilian strain is
more concerning and that's a little
different from the south african strain
there's sort of three variants we're
following uk
south africa and then this brazilian
variant
and the brazilian variant was just
discovered in missouri
and they reported somebody who was sick
who tested positive that person was sick
back in the first week of january
so what does that tell you about how at
large that strain
is right now so they're really spreading
more doctor they're spreading more than
we think
or than we've been had reports of
correct i think it's a mathematical
certainty that all three
strains are probably in every state in
the union
and then the vaccine do they cover them
all
yeah and so the vaccine will cover it
the vaccine will cover it
now we're not certain about the
brazilian strain it's just the tests
haven't been done yet
but the spike protein looks similar
enough where it probably is covered now
the bigger question is given the rate of
new mutations
and these new strains that are emerging
are we going to be able to keep up
at some point is it going to mutate
around the vaccine
and that's a very real and serious
question and the answer is maybe at some
point
maybe three years from now five years
from now
it could mutate around we do see that
with the seasonal flu every year
so we're going to be following this
carefully but modern has already started
started to do
research to say that your second dose
may be a little
different so that it captures some of
the newer
variants you can actually dial in uh
into the vaccine a way to address the
new variants
well let's hope let's hope this light is
coming at the end of that tunnel indeed
dr marty mccary
fox news contributor professor of
surgery and health policy at johns
hopkins university thank you again for
joining us
great to be with you dave
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
greg jarrett
what's on your mind here we go again
let's call it
impeachment the sequel it's destined to
be as
pitiable as the original like a cheap
movie franchise that hollywood keeps
exploiting
this sham version will be the equivalent
of a box office
dud the first impeachment trial in the
u.s senate a year ago was a baseless
fiasco that
ended in the easy acquittal of donald
trump
it's almost certain that the sequel will
mimic the same
bad ending pelosi and her colleagues
didn't bother to abide by their own
established rules that call for hearings
presentation of evidence and witnesses
the right to cross-examine those
witnesses the right of defense counsel
to be present
and the right of an accused to mount his
own defense
republican senators are sure to assail
the trampling
of fundamental rights that are a
cherished part
of any trial process including
impeachment
this will be the subject of a motion to
dismiss the impeachment
which should also argue that the senate
lacks jurisdiction to hold an
impeachment trial of a private citizen
who cannot be removed from office
obviously it's impossible to expel a
person from an office
he's already left take a moment to read
article 2
of the u.s constitution it states the
president
shall be removed from office on
impeachment and conviction
trump is no longer president biden is
we have one president at a time some
have argued that the value of a
retroactive senate impeachment trial is
to bar trump from
holding future federal office but read
the constitution
it indicates that disqualification from
office is a secondary purpose it's a
separate vote
it can only happen after the senate
decides on removal
in other words it's an optional
discretionary
and contingent penalty without removal
there can be no disqualification it
would be
constitutionally invalid if the motion
to dismiss
fails and it probably will trump's
defenders
will be forced to argue the case based
on the merits
did trump truly incite an insurrection
take a look at what trump said on
january 6 to the crowd
quote i know that everyone here will
soon be marching over to the capitol
building to peacefully
and patriotically make your voices heard
nowhere in trump's remarks did he
advocate violence
or destruction of property encouraging a
public
demonstration is not the same thing as
inciting
criminal acts there's a big difference
between rousing passions in a speech
all politicians do that and inciting an
insurrection
the violence on our nation's capital was
grotesque and disgraceful
those who committed the crimes must be
prosecuted
and punished however what happened there
does not constitute grounds for
impeaching trump nor should congress be
permitted
to compound the tragedy by contorting
the meaning of
impeachment for political gain or
persecution
it's time to end the politics of revenge
an assault on our seat of government
should not give rise to an assault
on our constitution i'm greg jarrett
fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app
download it today love fox news click
the subscribe button to get more of the
news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes